hi guys scifi recapped here before we
start warning spoilers ahead
today i'm gonna explain a 2015 american
science fiction and action movie called
jupiter ascending
the movie begins with maximilian jones
an astrophysics lecturer who meets
alaska in the middle of the night while
he is looking at the sky through his
telescope long story short they fall in
love and alaska is pregnant with jones
child he wants to name the baby jupiter
but she is not too fond of the name
saying that they cannot name a child
after a planet suddenly a group of
robbers break into the couple's house
and one of them attempts to take the
telescope away
jones tries to stop them but a robber
shoots him in the stomach killing him on
the spot after that incident alaska
decides to move from russia to america
somewhere in the middle of the atlantic
with the help of other passengers she
gives birth to the child and decides to
name her jupiter back to the present day
jupiter works as a janitor in a cleaning
service company in chicago
on the valentine planet where the people
were just being harvested the abrasive
siblings titus and khaliq are talking
about the harvest the sister says that
the victims feel no pain at all and the
harvest procedure was being done in a
humane way
suddenly their elder brother and the
successor of the abrasax empire balaam
shows up and it is revealed that their
mother has died and balaam is the one
who ordered the planet harvest
titus later mentions a very rare and
beautiful planet owned by their mother
called earth
back to earth jupiter continues living
her boring life as a janitor moving from
house to house to clean up her client's
house
at some point she claims that she hates
her life
three intergalactic bounty hunters falk
razzo and ebis are waiting outside
jupiter's apartment when they spot a
lycontent named kane wise near the area
they realize that he is after jupiter as
well and decide to go after him he
breaks into a building where he checks a
patient's record called catherine
dunlevy realizing that he is being
stalked kane emerges from the building
with his hover boots defending himself
with his shield from the hunters it's a
versus one condition he tries to shoot
back and the bullet hits one of the
hunters but he realizes that he cannot
beat them so he flees from there
unharmed
in abersax factory balaam meets mr
knight and mr skalikon who tell him that
they sent a group of alien creatures
called the keepers to earth and they
have identified a gene print of
catherine dunlevy who they believe are
the reincarnation of balaam's mother
balaam orders them to kill the woman
immediately
turns out that catherine dunlevy is
jupiter's roommate she is getting ready
to go out but the keepers appear in the
apartment and incapacitate catherine
jupiter tries to take a picture of them
with her phone but suddenly the phone
rings the keepers then chase after her a
few moments later the girls wake up and
they don't seem to remember anything
because the keepers have deleted their
short-term memory later that night
jupiter attends a family dinner at his
uncle's house vasseli she wants to
borrow money from vassily but he refuses
to give her the money and makes a rude
remark accusing her of using the money
for useless stuff
alaska is unhappy and tries to defend
her daughter though the rest of the
family seems to agree with the uncle
because of that jupiter withdraws the
request
turns out that jupiter wants to buy a
telescope with that money her cousin
vladi comes into her room and suggests
she go to the clinic and donates her
eggs for money she agrees to it even
though she has to split the earnings
with him
the next day while waiting at the clinic
she finds the alien photograph on her
phone but she can't remember about it it
is also revealed that she deliberately
used katherine's name to register to the
clinic during the surgery the doctors
and nurses tie her up and attempt to
kill her
luckily kane shows up on time and
eliminates all of them who turn out to
be the keepers sent by balaam he takes
jupiter out of there in a spacecraft
titus is informed by his aide families
that kane has jupiter with him
jupiter awakens and attempts to shoot
kane with a gun
he explains to her that he is a
genome-engineered human made up of a
splice between a human and a wolf that's
why he is called lycant when they are
about to ascend to his spaceship
suddenly they are attacked by the
hunters sent by balaam who also destroy
kane's ship with his hover boots kane
protects and takes jupiter away from the
attackers
the girl falls in the attack but he
manages to catch her before she gets hit
by the train he then hijacks one of the
planes and tries to attack back slowly
but surely kane manages to eliminate all
the hunters and escapes with jupiter
balum sees jupiter in the clinic and
confirms that she is really the
reincarnation of his mother he warns mr
sulkin not to fail again or he will
regret it the next day both of them
drive away from the city while on their
way kane explains to jupiter about the
abersax family which he claims to be the
strongest dynasty in the universe he
also reveals that he is hired by titus
to find her but he decides not to bring
her to him they eventually arrive at
kane's former comrade at the legionnaire
stinger who currently lives with his
sick daughter kaiser he immediately
punches kane and the two fight for a
short period of time until they are
surprised when they see jupiter can
control the bee swarms who are
genetically designed to recognize
royalty stinger realizes who she really
is and starts calling her your majesty
when stinger treats kane's wounds it is
revealed that both of them were
skyjackers who used to have wings the
men realize that jupiter is a recurrence
which makes things more complicated to
bring jupiter out of earth kane calls
the aegis space cops to help them
realizing that the hunters are going
after them they prepare the weapons to
defend themselves
stinger tells jupiter that the
lichentent got kicked from the army
because he attacked one of the royal
family members and stinger took the
blame he also reveals that the first
human was born on a planet called aorus
not earth
at the time they arrived at earth it was
inhabited by dinosaurs and they decided
to launch a large-scale extinction event
to eliminate all dinosaurs
he adds that earth was seeded by abras
industries and once the population
exceeds the planet's ability to sustain
it it is considered ripe for harvest to
be exact humans are going to get
harvested
not long after the bounty hunters and a
few keepers come up across stinger's
home they engage in a gunfight and
stinger attempts to protect jupiter from
being attacked
jupiter tries to escape through a tall
grass field but falk finds her and blows
her away with his weapon
she almost gets killed but razo and ebis
come to help her and kill falk they
capture jupiter and ascend on their ship
but kane manages to latch onto the ship
as it departs from earth jupiter is
brought to a distant planet where the
hunters decide to trade jupiter with
premium abersax nectar a few moments
later khaliq welcomes jupiter and shows
her a statue of her mother that looks
exactly like jupiter revealing that she
is a reincarnation of her mother she
tells her that she is 14 000 years old
and explains that her mother was 90 000
years old when she was murdered
later on colleek shows jupiter something
unexplainable
she walks into a full bath of nectar and
immediately transforms into a much
younger version of herself
after that colleek suggests jupiter to
claim her title as abrasak's family
member because the earth will belong to
her once she claims it kane breaks into
the palace and eliminates several guards
there using his hover boots he
approaches jupiter and attempts to shoot
colleek in order for jupiter to properly
stake her claim on earth she hands over
jupiter to kane and later she is brought
to aurus by the aegis which is led by
commander diomica singh
on the other side mr sulkan is punished
by balaam because of his second failure
to capture jupiter he then orders mr
griegan to bring the girl to him upon
arrival at the commonwealth ministry
jupiter meets bob an android lawyer who
will help her complete the ascension
process
she has to go through a long-winded and
inefficient bureaucracy process which
makes the android annoyed and decides to
bribe one of the officers
after that she is finally printed with a
tattoo on her wrist and is officially
allowed to claim ownership of earth
jupiter asks kane why he still wants to
help even after he resigns from titus he
answers that it's because he will have
the opportunity to get back to legion if
he helps her but we know that there's
something more than that
suddenly stinger shows up and betrays
his old friend deciding to bring jupiter
to titus upon arrival titus gives her a
warm welcome and offers her to dinner
with him which she agrees to besides
that kane is detained and stinger is
given a nectar to cure his daughter as a
reward titus explains to jupiter that
kane will be returned to deadland
because he broke their contract he is
aware that jupiter has fallen in love
with the lykenton he then brings her to
a room where a lot of nectars are being
stored
there titus reveals that nectar is
refined from approximately a hundred
human beings and earth as a farm he also
states that her mother was killed
because she tried to stop the human
harvesting business
he lies about wanting to continue her
mother's legacy and needs jupiter's help
thus he proposes to her but she
hesitates and doesn't answer him
immediately
titus tells kane that he plans to kill
jupiter after marrying her and claims
the earth after that he is expelled into
the void with his hands cuffed
luckily he uses his hover boots to burn
the cuffs off and grab a floating
spacesuit which saves him from
suffocation
unfortunately he only has 40 minutes of
oxygen but the aegis suddenly emerged
from hyperspace and rescue him
back to earth mr griegan and his lizard
army show up at jupiter's house and
capture all of her family titus
convinces jupiter to marry him saying
that marriage is just a contract in
order to protect innocent people which
are humans on earth after knowing that
kane was kicked out from the spaceship
she finally agrees to marry him in
exchange of cain and stinger's freedom
and they can get their roll back in the
legion in the aegis even after getting
betrayed kane asks for stinger's help to
rescue jupiter stinger apologizes and
reveals that he did that to get a nectar
for his daughter they immediately head
to titus's spaceship with flying war
pods titus realizes this and orders his
men to prevent them from coming close to
the ship the wedding is about to take
place titus has his ring printed on his
finger during the ceremony jupiter also
nearly has hers printed on when kane
suddenly breaks into the cathedral and
immediately points a gun towards titus
jupiter says that she only wants to go
home and they head back to earth
on their way jupiter gives kane a badge
as a sign that he and stinger are now
officially skyjackers again
upon arrival mr knight welcomes her and
offers her to come with him to meet
balaam if she wants to save her family
she is then brought to the abersox
factory the aegis are close behind but
are unable to enter the planet because
it is protected by a cloud shield she
finally meets balaam in person
jupiter figures out that he is the one
who killed his own mother because of his
greed
balaam then hands over a contract to
jupiter forcing her to abdicate her
title and return it to its natural heir
to convince her he shows her imprisoned
family and the floor beneath them
left with no option she has to agree if
she wants to save her family but she
then realizes that they will still die
since balaam would harvest them on earth
so she refuses and smashes the contract
in the aegis kane decides to go through
the thick cloud shield in order to save
his lover he barely makes it but
eventually arrives at the factory and
begins to seek out jupiter because kane
entered the shield by force he broke the
shield and a huge explosion occurred
causing a sudden chaos in the factory
kane shows up at the facility and pulls
jupiter out of balaam's room with a
special device
outside the planet starts to destabilize
and collapse
realizing that singh orders her pilot to
get into the planet in order to evacuate
kane and jupiter the skyjacker fights
balaam's men while jupiter rescues her
family out of the facility balaam then
confronts jupiter and attempts to kill
her himself
on the other side kane is confronted by
griegan and is forced to fight him
after a long fight kane manages to trap
the lizard by using his special device
after defeating the lizard he
immediately brings all jupiter's family
members back to the aegis back to
jupiter she attempts to run away from
balaam but he manages to spot her and
hits her she fights back and launches
her counter-attack against him
suddenly the platform they are standing
on breaks slightly balaam is unable to
hold on and he plummets to his death
jupiter also falls but is rescued by
cane they barely make it to the aegis
but luckily all of them manage to escape
the crumbling facility and get out
safely
jupiter and her family are taken back to
earth they erase jupiter's family's
memory and they continue their life as
if nothing has happened her aunt and
mother are confused when they see their
daughter's behavior has changed
drastically
she also continues working as a janitor
even after claiming the earth at the
family dinner the family surprised her
by bringing out the telescope she wanted
she then tells them that she has a date
jupiter meets kane on the rooftop of a
building he finally has his wings back
while jupiter has gotten hover boots of
her own the couple then kiss and take
flight over the city
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching